[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans ce 7 études de
rentrée sur TV 78 dans l'actualité de ce
lundi 4 septembre c'est la rentrée pour
près de 300 6000 élèves dans les
Yvelines un retour sur les bancs de
l'école particulier à La Verrière ou
deux établissements ont été touchés par
des incendies lors des émeuses
d'urbaines en juin dernier conséquence
la commune est polluée par l'État et les
collectivités a dû s'organiser pour que
173 élèves puissent revenir en classe
dès aujourd'hui depuis 2010 la Journée
mondiale de la santé sexuelle se tient
tous les Quatre Septembre à un
rendez-vous qui permet de mettre en
avant les questions autour de la
sexualité écoute prévention dépistage ou
contraception présentation des
différents organismes recevant du public
sur cette thématique dans les Yvelines
comme chaque lundi l'actualité sportive
du week-end dans le département la
sélection de rugby du Pays de Galles a
été accueilli ce dimanche ville ou à la
établi son camp de base pendant la coupe
du monde qui débute vendredi en baseball
les Cougars de Montigny-le-Bretonneux
sont en finale du championnat de France
et puis les invités du 7-8 en deuxième
partie d'émission en ce jour de retour
en classe on fait le point justement sur
les nouveautés de la rentrée et plus
précisément dans les lycées franciliens
interview avec Valérie Pécresse et
othmann nasru présidente et
vice-président de la Région
Île-de-France
une rentrée scolaire un peu particulière
pour les écoliers de la verrière les 173
élèves de l'école élémentaire du bois de
l'étang se sont rendus ce matin devant
leur établissement incendié pendant les
émeutes enfant et famille ont été
accueillis par le maire de la ville
Nicolas Dainville et la Présidente de la
Région Île-de-France Valérie Pécresse
malgré l'émotion tout est mis en place
pour que cette rentrée soit une réussite
ça a été beaucoup de boulot il a fallu
faire venir du mobilier spécifique pour
les enfants il a fallu harmoniser les
tarifs de cantine c'est la région qui
payera la
différence de tarifs entre le lycée le
primaire et puis il a fallu mettre en
place les navettes des navettes
évidemment gratuites que
Île-de-France mobilité prend en charge
donc c'est un effort financier mais
c'est surtout voilà le fruit d'un
travail collectif pour
bien accueillir ses enfants cette
rentrée et que les émeutiers n'est pas
gagné des ce matin des cartes gratuits
ont été mis à disposition des élèves
direction l'école régionale du 1er degré
le nouvel établissement des enfants un
changement d'organisation mais surtout
un soulagement pour les familles c'est
une rentrée un peu particulière mais bon
comme je disais tout à l'heure on sera
là c'est un peu difficile pour les
enfants mais
voilà quoi les enfants vont prendre un
rythme un peu spécial parce que c'est
vrai que au bois de l'étang on va quand
il est allé à l'école ils se réveillait
un peu plus tard là du fait ils vont se
réveiller un peu plus tôt nous on était
pas loin de ce qui s'était passé c'était
un peu compliqué au final ça se règle
c'est particulier la rentrée j'ai
entendu qu'il y avait des écoles qui
pouvaient pas rouvrir
donc j'imagine pas j'imagine même pas
comment les parents doivent être et pour
organiser cette rentrée les équipes
étaient sur le pied de guerre cet été
pour pouvoir accueillir les élèves dans
les meilleures conditions il y a
quelques jours ces derniers ont pu
visiter leur nouvelle établissement avec
leurs parents en compagnie de l'équipe
pédagogique une manière de mieux
appréhender cette rentrée
ça change après deux mois deux travaux
acharnés tout est désormais prêt pour
les nouveaux arrivants les équipes
municipales ont été exceptionnelles nos
partenaires ont été
si précieux pour tout arranger pour tout
aménager pour tout finaliser à temps et
pour réaliser une prouesse accueillir
dans cette école régionale de 1er degré
près de 180 enfants en aménageant cette
nouvelle salle de classe ce qui n'est
pas rien en réglant les soucis de
navette pour amener les enfants de
cantine d'accueil donc
on est très satisfait et satisfait les
parents le sont aussi pour moi oui ça va
ils ont bien aménagé les locaux et ça me
convient cette école c'est magnifique
c'est joli par rapport à l'autre l'école
de bas de l'étang cette cohabitation
entre les deux groupes scolaires
devraient durer au moins trois ans le
temps nécessaire à la reconstruction de
l'école du bois de l'ét ang
méconnu est souvent tabou la santé
sexuelle est mise en lumière le 4
septembre lors de sa journée mondiale
j'ai quoi comme choix de contraception
l'Organisation mondiale de la santé la
définit comme un état de bien-être
physique mental et social associé à la
sexualité un vaste domaine lié à
l'aspect sanitaire au respect entre
partenaires ou à la procréation dans le
département des Yvelines différents
organismes existent pour se renseigner
se faire dépister ou recevoir des
traitements en toute confidentialité et
gratuitement né d'un mouvement féministe
il y a 60 ans l'association planning
familial offre un espace de discussion
au public et informe sur la santé
sexuelle contraception avortement
orientation ou encore violence ici au
Mureaux les conseillers reçoivent les
bénéficiaires avec ou sans rendez-vous
des animations en groupe sont également
proposées l'idée c'est de pouvoir
libérer la parole grâce à des
jeux le plus souvent donc des activités
plutôt ludiques mais qui sont souvent en
fait un prétexte
pour venir se questionner sur sur notre
vie affective et sexuelle qu'on donne
des informations quand on peut les
donner et puis après les personnes font
leur propre choix en fonction de ce dont
elles ont besoin tout comme le planning
familial le centre de santé sexuelle
accueille le public pour l'informer et
l'écouter mission du Conseil
départemental ce lieu permettait aussi
des consultations médicales grâce à des
médecins et des sages-femmes présents
sur place accès à la contraception
dépistage et traitement contre les
infections sexuellement transmissibles
sont quelques-uns des actes pratiqués
ici à Plaisir la santé sexuelle fait
partie de la santé générale et la
sexualité est un une partie importante
du bien-être par exemple quelqu'un qui
aurait été victime de violences
sexuelles peut être amenée à avoir des
conduites alimentaires troublées et
voilà on peut se demander pourquoi telle
personne et sur le chemin de l'obésité
et ben oui c'est lié à la santé sexuelle
d'autres plateformes existent pour
s'informer sur ces différents thèmes et
épreuves de l'importance de la santé
sexuelle dans notre société l'OMS a
lancé début 2023 une stratégie pour
lutter contre la conduite sexuelle
dans le reste de l'actualité les Restos
du Coeur sont en proie des difficultés
financières l'association s'est résignée
à réduire son nombre de bénéficiaires
c'est environ 150 000 personnes
concernées selon Patrice douret
président de l'association la raison la
hausse du nombre de demandeurs et des
coûts de fonctionnement dues à
l'inflation face à cela le gouvernement
promet 15 millions d'euros d'aide
supplémentaires dans les Yvelines les
restos du cœur oppèrent dans 27 centres
d'activités
la chaleur fait son grand retour cette
semaine en Île-de-France et températures
atteindront jusqu'à 33 degrés dans
certains départements l'agence régionale
de santé conseille de s'hydrater
régulièrement et de rester au frais
ce week-end c'était la 13ème édition
d'électrique Park un festival de musique
électro après un week-end au rythme bien
élevé sur l'île des Impressionnistes à
Chatou le bilan est un succès sur ces
deux jours 80 artistes se sont succédés
sur cinq scènes avec des DJ
internationaux comme Robin Schulz Ghost
Rider ou encore le duo Infected Mushroom
pour le plus grand plaisir de plus de
30000 festivaliers
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les cougars peuvent rougir de plaisir
ils viennent de se qualifier pour la
finale du championnat de France de
première division une victoire acquise
au bout du suspense contre les Templiers
de senara menaient de victoire à une des
joueurs de Montigny-le-Bretonneux en
suranversé la tendance ce dimanche 3
septembre remportant les deux matchs
c'est pas facile hein on finit en
dixième manche avec un point d'avance
quoi on pensait pouvoir faire ça un peu
plus rapidement mais au fait ils nous
ont quand même donné du fil à retordre
et c'était pas évident ici ils ont été
ils ont été assez bons pendant le
week-end donc non pas facile une
demi-finale pas facile quoi mais bon au
final c'est nous qui gagnons cette
finale de première division de baseball
sera la deuxième de l'histoire des
Cougars de Montigny-le-Bretonneux après
2018 pour le club c'est très très
historique c'est un club que moi quand
j'ai commencé j'ai un prix d'ici je
viens du Pic du Paris et à l'époque ils
avaient 0 victoire et là maintenant on
gagne un championnat à challenge et on
est en finale du championnat et on va en
Coupe d'Europe l'année prochaine grâce à
ça les joueursont contre les Barracuda
de Montpellier l'équipe du sud de la
France a terminé première de l'autre
poule du championnat de France de D1 et
non c'est une grosse équipe ça va être
compliqué ça va être compliqué ça va
être aussi dur qu'aujourd'hui mais on a
nos chances c'est c'est comme tout dans
le sport
c'est pas sans qu'on n'a pas joué tant
que la dernière balle n'a pas été lancée
tout peut arriver et du coup on y va
pour aller gagner la finale les cougars
devront vite se remettre de leurs
émotions pour la grande finale recevront
Montpellier au stade Jean maréchal ce
samedi 9 et dimanche 17 septembre les
Yvelinois joueront le weekend suivant à
l'extérieur il faudra trois victoires
aux animaux pour soulever la coupe
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on commence par du rugby les joueurs du
Pays de Galles sont arrivés ce dimanche
soir à Versailles une ville qui sera
leur camp de base pendant toute la Coupe
du monde de rugby pour l'occasion une
cérémonie avec des jeunes du Rugby Club
de Versailles 400 invités étaient
organisées dans les salons de la mairie
si on a voulu accueillir une équipe pour
cette Coupe du Monde c'est vraiment pour
signifier que Versailles c'est une ville
du sport c'est une ville où il y a
beaucoup d'adhérents beaucoup aussi une
diversité des sports et donc c'est un
grand plaisir d'avoir eu ce bel ambiance
ce soir les 33 dragon rouge accompagnés
par 29 membres du staff seront à
Versailles jusqu'au 9 octobre ils
logeront Trianon Palace et ils sont très
longs au stade de Porchefontaine deux
entraînements seront ouverts au public
le vendredi 29 septembre et le lundi 2
octobre en tennis livinoir turiner s'est
arrêté au troisième tour de l'US Open
après avoir éliminé l'italien Matéo
Berettini le jour originaire de Saint
jean-mans les a perdu en 4,7 contre le
9e jour mondial le russe Andreï rouble
le score 3 6 6 3 600 7 5 Arthur hinder
knash était le dernier Français en lice
dans les tableaux de simple ce troisième
tour était le meilleur résultat de sa
carrière dans un tournoi du Grand Chelem
en football le pissa qui est Matéo
Guendouzi jouera la saison prochaine du
côté de Rome après deux saisons passées
sur la Canebière à Marseille le joueur
formé au Paris Saint-Germain a été prêté
à la Lazio de Rome avec une option
d'achat obligatoire de 12 millions
d'euros hors bonus pour son premier
match ce week-end contre Naples Matéo
Guendouzi a marqué mais son but a été
refusé par la Varin il aura de nouveau
l'occasion d'ouvrir son compteur contre
la Juventus Turin le 16 septembre
toujours en football la décision est
tombée l'équipe seigneur du Poissy
Football Club évoluera en première
division de district cette année la
décision a été annoncée la semaine
dernière les dirigeants de cette
nouvelle structure qui remplacent lace
Poissy penser pouvoir évoluer la saison
prochaine un niveau au dessus en
régional 3 la reprise de la compétition
pour les seniors et programmer le 24
septembre enfin au golf l'Open de France
sera de retour au Golf National de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines pour une 105e
édition du 21 au 24 septembre était
d'affiche françaises quand Victor Pérez
ou livinois Antoine Rosner devrait être
présent sur les greens si vous êtes
intéressé la billetterie est ouverte
demain mardi les conditions météo
exceptionnelles pour la période vont se
poursuivre ça devrait être le cas pour
une bonne partie de la semaine mardi
matin grand soleil sur tout le
territoire Yves Linois les températures
seront au dessus des 20 degrés
l'après-midi il va faire très chaud
jusqu'à 33 degrés dans les secteurs de
Houdan et de Rambouillet comptez 32
degrés à Mantes-la-Jolie 31 à Versailles
ce mardi 5 septembre nous fêterons les
Raïssa tout de suite les invités du 7 8
[Musique]
c'est la rentrée également dans
469 lycées publics d'Île-de-France
bonjour Valérie Pécresse bonjour hot
président de la région de France et
présidente bien sûr de cette région
Île-de-France alors vous avez parlé ce
matin lors d'une conférence de presse
des nouveautés de la rentrée ici au
siège de la région à Saint-Ouen alors en
cette rentrée on parle encore de pouvoir
d'achat avec l'inflation qui est
galopante la région Île-de-France va
notamment maintenir le gel du tarif dans
les cantines pour plus de la moitié des
familles pourquoi c'est important pour
la région de maintenir ce gel vous savez
que depuis trois ans nous avons gelé
tous les tarifs de cantine pour
justement essayer de préserver le
pouvoir d'achat des familles face à
l'inflation alors on peut pas tenir
indéfiniment comme ça mais cette année
nous maintiendrons ce gel pour plus de
50% des familles c'est à dire que
jusqu'à un revenu de 4000 euros par
couple avec deux enfants et bien il y
aura le gel des tarifs il faut savoir
qu'un repas Constantine c'est un coup de
10 euros et que les prix aujourd'hui en
Île-de-France des tarifs c'est entre 50
centimes et 4,40 donc la région
subventionne près de 60 plus de 60% de
tous les repas des quantités alors il y
a aussi la fourniture pour les élèves
qui rentrent en seconde d'un ordinateur
ça c'est pas une nouveauté mais en tout
cas cette année ils vont avoir une
mémoire augmenter c'est bien ça
absolument une mémoire augmenter qui
représente à peu près un coup de 5
millions d'euros pour la région parce
que et bien on a de plus en plus
d'usages de cet ordinateur
plus la moitié des professeurs demande
très fréquemment aux élèves de la porter
et ces ordinateurs ils sont en tout cas
utilisés à 100% pour faire les devoirs à
la maison c'est un très gros outil
d'égalité de tous ces jeunes fassent à
au numérique et ça permet de mettre tous
les élèves vraiment dans une tendance
situation dans des conditions
identiques d'apprentissage ce qui était
très important pour moi parce que vous
le savez en Île-de-France nous avons 35%
d'élèves boursiers qui n'ont pas
forcément accès à un ordinateur
personnel à la maison et représente avec
les manuels numériques qui sont
embarqués un coup de 600 euros pour pour
un élève de seconde 270 en première 240
euros en terminale il y a une nouveauté
d'ailleurs en cette rentrée 2023 pour
accompagner les jeunes c'est le
lancement de l'application là-bas ce qui
sera disponible sur Google Play aussi
sur l'App Store alors la base
concrètement si une application qui va
recenser donc les aides et bons plans
pour les jeunes de la région les 15-25
ans absolument les jeunes de 15-25 ans
trouveront sur la base toutes les aides
de la Région alors ça peut être des
aides transport on a une aide de 100
euros pour l'achat d'un vélo on a une
aide de 400 euros pour l'achat d'un vélo
électrique ça peut être aussi pour
pratiquer une activité culturelle ou
sportive ils auront un portefeuille de
100 euros qui pourront utiliser pour
soit s'inscrire dans une dans un club
sportif soit s'inscrire dans un
conservatoire par exemple et puis il y
aura tous les bons plans de la région
c'est à dire
la billetterie sociale des olympiques et
paralympique 4000 places pour la Coupe
du monde de rugby un certain nombre de
places de concerts que nous avons et que
nous mettons à leur disposition il y a
aussi l'accompagnement des jeunes
notamment dans la lutte contre le
décrochage scolaire alors vous avez
parlé vous votre Madness matin du
lancement Dorian est-ce que vous pouvez
nous en dire un peu plus quel est le
concept comment ça comment ça marche oui
on a créé en Île de France avec la
prison de la région une agence dédiée à
la réussite à la promesse républicaine à
l'orientation qui s'appelle Oriane et
qui va aller chercher tous les jeunes
que nous n'arrivons pas à atteindre
aujourd'hui pour leur proposer des
formations la découverte des bons
métiers qui recrutent aujourd'hui en
Île-de-France et qui sont pas toujours
connus des jeunes on allant les chercher
là où ils sont sur les territoires on
aura un bus de l'orientation qui va
sillonner l’île-de-france à partir du
mois d'octobre mais aussi sur les
formats numériques aujourd'hui qui sont
utilisés par nos jeunes il y a cette
application la base dont tu as parlé à
la prison de la région mais il y aura
aussi la capacité à aller chercher ceux
qui sont en décrochage sur les réseaux
sociaux aller repérer à les mobiliser ça
sera aussi la capacité d'aller leur
proposer toutes les aides que nous avons
aujourd'hui mis en place avec par
exemple le permis de conduire que nous
prenons en charge en Île-de-France en en
finance 3000 désormais tous les mois et
puis toutes les formations aussi qui
sont proposées avec par exemple le
revenu jeune actif c'est-à-dire une
formation professionnelle qualifiante et
bien et un revenu pour pouvoir suivre
cette formation à condition d'aller au
bout faire un métier qui nous mène à la
réussite et c'est tout ce travail
d'insertion qui a été voulu par la
présidence on a tout remis à plat avec
un souci d'efficacité parce qu'on doit à
chacun de nos jeunes et bien de leur
proposer un chemin vers la réussite sur
tous les territoires en Île-de-France et
puis en cette rentrée 2023 il y a bien
sûr la poursuite du plan d'urgence pour
les lycées on le rappelle 6,6 milliards
d'euros qui sont alloués à cet
investissement c'est le troisième poste
de dépenses en France c'est ça troisième
plan d'investissement derrière le Grand
Paris est derrière les Jeux olympiques
et paralympiques de Paris 2024 alors
avec plusieurs chantiers notamment des
chantiers d'envergure qui ont déjà été
livrés on peut parler peut-être du lycée
Jules Ferry à Versailles puisque ça
concerne les Yvelines qui est donc livré
un grand chantier de rénovation oui un
grand chantier de rénovation Jules Ferry
qui était très attendu avec des ateliers
avec la demi-pension toujours très
compliqué de faire des travaux dans un
site historique avec à Versailles et
puis nous avons trois chantiers en cours
nous avons un chantier dans le lycée de
Carrières-sur-Seine dans le lycée de
Sartrouville grosse restructuration et
dans le lycée de Mantes-la-Ville donc
vous voyez quatre lycées
des Yvelines qui font l'objet de travaux
de grandes structuration après tous ceux
que nous avons déjà livré à
Saint-Germain-en-Laye le lycée
international de Buc le lycée de
Saint-Germain et les lycées de lycée de
Poissy qui sont aussi en train d'être
rénovés l'objectif c'est 30000 nouvelles
places d'ici la fin de votre mandat il y
en a déjà 10 000 qui ont été livrés oui
on a 30
000 nouvelles places à créer alors
pourquoi parce que la région est une
région qui a une très forte dynamique
démographique nous sommes une région
parmi les plus jeunes de France mais
aussi parce que et bien les quitte Paris
elle quitte Paris pour s'installer en
petite couronne et en grande couronne
avec leurs enfants et donc il faut qu'on
adapte notre offre scolaire à cette
nouvelle donne démographique et à
l'attractivité des départements
notamment en grande couronne c'est pour
ça que cette année nous ouvrons 1400
places seulement en grande couronne et
il y a un sujet dernier sujet en cette
rentrée bien sûr solide la laïcité avec
notamment les annonces du ministre de
l'éducation nationale Gabriel Attal on
peut citer l'interdiction la volonté du
gouvernement d'interdire la Baya dans
dans les établissements scolaires est-ce
que vous avez l'impression qu'il y a une
nouvelle donne qui est donnée par le
gouvernement qu'est-ce que vous pensez
de ces nouvelles annonces
d'abord ce que je veux dire c'est que la
loi de 2004 qui prohib tous les signes
ostentatoires religieux pour moi à
l'évidence interdit la Baya ou le
Camille dans les établissements
scolaires mais le problème c'est que sur
ce sujet là on a laissé les proviseurs
et les équipes pédagogiques seuls pour
faire appliquer cette loi de 2004 et
donc moi je me félicite que le ministre
de l'éducation nationale et enfin eu une
période claire sur ce sujet parce que
j'alertais sur les difficultés
qu'avaient les proviseurs face à des
jeunes qui
venaient de plus en plus dans des tenues
qui n'étaient pas réglementaires donc il
s'agit juste de faire appliquer purement
simplement la loi de 2004 toute la loi
de 2004 alors cette application ne va
pas être facile parce que dans certains
établissements yon le sait aujourd'hui
des habitudes ont été prises voilà et
donc il va falloir faire preuve de
pédagogie de fermeté et il va surtout
falloir être aux côtés des équipes de
direction et les équipes pédagogiques
dans les lycées en tout cas la région
sera aux côtés de ces agents et si
quiconque ça vise de les menacer nous
nous leur donnerons la protection
fonctionnelle de la région un dernier
mot pour tous les deux pour les lycéens
justement qui font leur entrée qu'est-ce
que vous avez envie de leur dire et bien
que nous vous en maximum pour les
réussites et qu'on leur souhaite bonne
chance et une très belle année surtout
la région Île-de-France et la région de
tous les possibles et quand on est
lycéen en Île-de-France on a vraiment
toutes les chances de réussir des
équipes pédagogiques magnifiques et des
lycées qui se rénovent avec un plan
unique en France merci Valérie Pécresse
merci
otman Nasro d'avoir été avec nous pour
cette première de rentrer du 7 8 très
belle soirée sur TV 78
[Musique]